can you talk for a moment one about
letting our past dictate how far we go
you talk about some things in the film
about healing from dramatic instances I
think a lot of us hold on to our
Achilles heel and say oh well we can't
do this because we don't have enough
money the brother was the star of the
family no one supports me how do we move
past that obviously you have your here
in LA for screening how do we not wear
our labels and then let it hold us back
well i think in letting go of our
victims story one of the things that
that i learned and that's the key we've
got to let go of that victims story one
of the key things is we realize in the
process of letting go of our
victimization we're going to be tested
on that because one day we might do
really well and you say I've got this
I've got it figured out no longer am I
going to come from my victims story
which a big one of mine along the themes
of trust is people don't do what they
say they're going to do that was what
happened to me as a child someone was
going to help me and then they didn't
and so that meant you know it wasn't
just one time I got to let go of that
victims story but over and over over
again and I no longer saw that is that
there's something wrong that I'm not yet
doing it's just like oh there it is
again you just recognize your shadow or
eat the parts of you that are unhealed
and said am I going to let this stop me
or mine to continue on and rise above
that challenge but you have to be
conscious of it so that's why sometimes
it comes back so many times this what
gay Hendrix called the the upper limit
problem and when we're starting to break
through right to another level or upper
limits going to keep us right where we
were unless we say I've got the courage
and the fortitude to rise above this
consciously
you